[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Christian Siebers guten Abend
ihnen allen wir haben uns schuldig
gemacht es wurde
weggesehen solche die das Versagen einer
ganzen Institution eingestehen kennen
wir praktisch wortgleich von
Würdenträgern der katholischen Kirche
als diese vor dem Unfassbaren Ausmaß von
sexuellem Missbrauch dort nicht länger
die Augen verschließen konnten die Sätze
die ich gerade zitiert habe kamen heute
aber von der kommissarischen
Ratsvorsitzenden der Evangelischen
Kirche in Deutschland für die ist das
heute ein schwarzer Tag ein beschämender
Tag es gibt viel mehr Missbrauch Opfer
als bekannt und gedacht auch in der
evangelischen Kirche eine großangelegte
Studie im Auftrag der EKD hat alle
Beschäftigten im evangelischen Leben in
den Blick genommen also auch
Heimerzieher Kirchenmusiker Leiter von
Jugendgruppen sie kommt auf fast 10 000
Kinder und Jugendliche die seit 1946
sexuell missbraucht wurden
Durchschnittsalter 11 Jahre die Zahl ist
hochgerechnet weil viele
fehlen und sie sei nur die Spitze des
Eisbergs Ulrike
rötle es ist ein Satz der in Erinnerung
bleibt als Katharina kracht vor das
mikrotritt sie wurde als Jugendliche von
einem Pfarrer missbraucht sie sagt die
evangelische Kirche habe die Aufklärung
von Missbrauch verhindert es ist genug
es ist schon lange
genug heute wurde der evangelischen
Kirche die Studie über sexualisierte
Gewalt übergeben und sie belegt es sind
keine Einzelfälle das war lange die
Haltung der Kirche nun müsse gehandelt
werden sagen die studienmacher die IKD
Vorsitzende will Verantwortung
übernehmen setzt aber bei der
Aufarbeitung auf die
Basis es muss von unten verstanden
werden es muss an jeder Gemeinde an
jedem Ort und in jeder Kita verstanden
werden was ein Schutzkonzept ist und es
muss umgesetzt
werden Stefan ren ist Mitglied der
aufarbeitungskommission des Bundes und
sagt die Studie lege offen dass die hier
mit der Aufarbeitung überfordert ist
jetzt zu sagen wir müssen erst gucken
dass die Basis mitgenommen wird das ist
letztlich ein Stück leitungsversagen
also es ist jetzt Aufgabe der Leitung
auch sich zu fragen wie können wir und
zwar von oben hinein in die Struktur
dafür sorgen dass wirklich jetzt ein
Ruck passiert dass wirklich Veränderung
passiert im Bereich der evangelischen
Kirche und der Diakonie
9355 Fälle sexualisierter Gewalt diese
Zahl nennen die Forscher heute
unfassbares Leid tausendfach das
Durchschnittsalter der Betroffenen etwa
11 Jahre die Täter meist aus den
Pfarreien männlich verheiratet doch die
Zahl sei spekulativ Räumen die
Forschenden ein eine selektive
Stichprobe der Grund sie hatten viel zu
wenig Einsicht in die Personalakten der
Landeskirchen auch Lisa Meer wurde
Gewalt angetan sie war damals 12 Jahre
alt und in Österreich auf einer
Ferienfreizeit sie möchte nicht erkannt
werden ihren Namen haben wir geändert er
ist ja in mich eingedrungen vaginal wie
anal
und auch mit Schmerzen verbunden und das
gewusst das ist nicht richtig das ist
falsch eine völlige Überforderung dieses
kleinen
Mädchens doch Lisa Meer kämpfte sie
wurde unter Druck gesetzt niemanden
etwas zu erzählen doch sie schwieg nicht
allerdings dauerte es Jahrzehnte bis ihr
jemand zuhörte ihr Fall wurde
schließlich nach zehn Verhandlungen mit
der Landeskirche anerkannt Betroffene
erleben sich auch ganz oft als
Bittsteller immer noch also ich sag
jetzt mal von Gottes Gnaden also was wir
bekommen was wir nicht bekommen wird uns
geglaubt wird uns nicht geglaubt
und das ist ein geschlossenes System und
in diesem geschlossenen System geht es
auch immer noch um
Machtmissbrauch es gibt viele Faktoren
die den Missbrauch begünstigt haben
heute ist klar geworden die evangelische
Kirche hat jetzt einen langen Weg vor
sich Dressing ist forensischer
Psychiater und hat an der Studie
mitgearbeitet Herr Professor guten Abend
guten Abend sie sagen sie haben die
Spitze des Eisbergs gefunden sie haben
aus diesen belegbaren Fällen jetzt ihre
Zahlen quasi hochrechnen müssen warum
konnten Sie denn den kompletten Eisberg
nicht direkt erforschen wir haben
eigentlich unserem Forschungsdesign
dieselbe Methode wählen wollen die wir
schon mal in der katholischen Kirche bei
der sogenannten MHG Studie verwendet
haben also eine
personalaktenanalyse die Zuarbeit
einzelner Landeskirchen war dann aber so
schleppend und die datengüte auch nicht
genügend dass wir in einen erheblichen
zeitlichen Verzug gekommen sind und die
angedachte personalaktenanalyse nicht
mehr durchführen konnten wir mussen uns
dann auf die
disziplinaraktenanalyse in den meisten
Landeskirchen beschränken und konnten
nur in einer Landeskirche die
Personalakten durchsehen und die Quote
die wir da gefunden haben und das haben
wir auch betont das hat erhebliche
Limitationen äh wenn man diese Quote
hochrechnen würde ähm was methodisch
sehr problematisch ist kä man auf die
Zahlen die genannt sind sie sagen
methodisch sehr problematisch sind denn
die wen zahlen dann noch viel höher oder
wie würden sie das Einschätzen in jedem
Fall wird auch eine personalakanalyse
nie das gesamte Ausmaß stattt gehabt der
sexualisier der Gewalt erfassen können
auch da kann man eigentlich nur die
Spitze des Eisbergs beschreiben wir
haben mit dem was wir jetzt ermitteln
konnten der evangelischen Kirche wir
haben das genannt es ist eigentlich die
Spitze der Spitze des Eisbergs weil wir
wesentlich weniger Quellen hatten als in
der katholischen Kirche also in der
katholischen Kirche haben wir mehr als
38 000 Personalakten durchgesehen in der
evangelischen Kirche etwa 6000 also
knapp ein Sechstel der Datenquellen sie
sagen die Zuarbeit einiger oder vieler
Landeskirchen der meisten Landeskirchen
sei sehr schleppend gewesen worauf füren
sie denn das jetzt zurück war das jetzt
schlicht Schlamperei oder machen sie da
eine vertuschungsabsicht fest ich kann
das letztendlich nicht entscheiden
welches Motiv es gewesen ist
möglicherweise ist auch ein Motivbündel
gewesen was wir sehen konnten in der
Zusammenarbeit war in vielen
Landeskirchen stand diese Thematik nicht
auf Top 1 der
Prioritätenliste die zur Verfügung
gestellten personellen Ressourcen in
Landeskirchen waren offensichtlich nicht
genügend also das mag ein Faktor sein ob
es andere Ursachen gab ob es wirklich
tatsächlich Vertuschung ist das kann ich
anhand der mir vorliegend gebis so nicht
feststellen jedenfalls hat das was
versprochen wurde vertraglich nicht
geklappt in unserer Studien wir haben
deshalb eine eingeschränkte Quellenlage
gucken wir mal inhaltlich in die Studie
noch ein Moment rein wenn wir dürfen
Herr Professor die in der Studie
aufgeführten Beschuldigten sind zum
weitüberwiegenden Teil männlich mehr als
zwei Drittel von ihnen seinen bei der
ersttat verheiratet gewesen das ist ja
schon interessant ist denn damit die
These die bei den Missbrauchsfällen in
der kischen Kirche häufiger genannt
wurde nämlich das liegt am zölibad ist
diese These widerlegt nein die ist nicht
widerlegt institutionelle
Rahmenbedingungen sind nie die Ursache
für sexualisierte Gewalt sondern sie
sind eine
ermöglichungsstruktur es bedarf immer
eines tatgeneigten Menschen der diese
ermögungsstrukturen missbraucht es gibt
spezifische Strukturen der katholischen
Kirche ist es unter Umständen der
Zölibat den gibt es in der evangelischen
Kirche nicht da gibt es andere
ermöglichungsstrukturen die dann
tatgeneigte Menschen nutzen um Kinder
sexuell zu missbrauchen was wären das
für Strukturen in der evangelischen
Kirche wir haben sehr
Punkte gefunden die für eine deutliche
verantwortungsdiffusion sprechen der
evangelischen Kirche
näher Distanz ist nicht gut geregelt das
evangelische pfahrhaus wäre ein solcher
typischer evangelischer
Ort wo sexualisierte Gewalt geschehen
ist und es ist extrem tabuisiert die
evangelische Kirche stellt sich ja
durchaus in ihrem Selbstverständnis als
die bessere Kirche da und in einer
solchen Institution ist es natürlich
besonders problematisch wenn solche
Taten geschehen und es besteht die
Tendenz das zu tabuisieren und auch zu
vertuschen sie haben es vorhin schon
ganz kurz angesprochen sie haben in
einer ähnlichen Studie über die
katholische Kirche mitgewirkt würden sie
jetzt sagen das was sie in der
evangelischen Kirche gefunden haben ist
noch schlimmer als in der katholischen
oder kann man das überhaupt nicht
vergleichen ich ich würde das nicht
vergleichen insbesondere wird es dem
Leid der Betroffenen auch nicht gerecht
es ist kein Betroffenen gedient damit zu
sagen die Katholen sind schlimmer oder
die Evangelien sind schlimmer die Folgen
für die Betroffenen sind gleich egal ob
sie jetzt von einem evangelischen einem
katholischen Pfarrer missbraucht werden
jetzt hatte man ja in der evangelischen
Kirche bislang immer mal wieder den
Eindruck die wollen sich auch so ein
bisschen verstecken hinter den Skandalen
der katholischen Kirche hat denn aus
ihrer Sicht die evangelische Kirche mit
dem heutigen Tag wenigst
auch die Größe des Ausmaß des Problems
erkannt also wie gesagt das
Ausmaß können wir derzeit wirklich nicht
abschätzen weil wir von einem sehr
starken Dunkelfeld ausgehen müssen und
von einer starken Unterschätzung der
zahlen was man aber sicher sagen kann
und ich denke was die evangelische
Kirche auch anerkennen muss und in ihren
Verlautbarungen heute auch getan hat ist
auch die evangelische Kirche hat ein
veritables Problem mit sexualisierter
Gewalt zum Nachteil von Kindern und
Jugendlichen sagt Professor Harald
Dressing einer der mitautore dieser
Studie heute Herr Professor vielen Dank
für das Gespräch bei uns gerne und das
Gespräch haben wir ganz kurz vor dieser
Sendung aufgezeichnet eine die
Selbstopfer sexuellen Missbrauchs in der
evangelischen Kirche wurde und jetzt mit
aufklären will ist nachher hier bei uns
im heute journal
Update kann man weltoffen werden mit
einer Werbekampagne wohl eher nicht kann
man Weltoffenheit zeigen mit einer
werbekamp
klar thüringen will genau das jetzt tun
im Freistaat haben Sie dazu ein Bündnis
geschmiedet wie es das dort noch nie zu
vorgab mit dabei Verbände Theater
Sportvereine und das fällt auf viele
Unternehmen große Firmen und kleine
Weltmarktführer für die Weltoffenheit
ein Standortfaktor ist ohne den es nicht
geht wenn man Händeringen Fachkräfte
sucht Bündnis weltoffenes Thüringen
schon länger geplant und doch so sagen
den Initiatoren gerade jetzt zur rechten
Zeit Daniela Sonntag mit
mir und deswegen werde ich dieses Land
nicht den menschenfiten überlassen
Videobotschaften für die Social Media
Kampagne viele Stimmen wollen sie
aufnehmen heute zum auftragt und
Vernetzungstreffen des Bündnisses
weltoffenes Thüringen noch nie haben
sich im Freistaat so viele und so viele
verschiedene Akteure für Vielfalt für
Demokratie zusammengeschlossen seit
Monaten vorbereitet auch von Erik
Thüringen wird wirklich wahrgenommen mit
diesen 30 35% für eine rechtsextreme
Partei und wir wollen zeigen Thüringen
ist sehr viel mehr Thüringen ist jetzt
schon vielfältig weltoffen die in
Thüringen als rechtsextrem eingestufte
AFD um Björn höcke liegt in Umfragen mit
Abstand vorn Abbild eines politischen
Klimas im Land das viele nicht mehr
hinnehmen wollen denn schon jetzt spüren
sie Auswirkungen wie an den Hochschulen
insbesondere bei Studien Bewerbern aber
auch bei jobbewerbern die aus den alten
Bundesländern kommen die uns zu
verstehen geben dass nach Thüringen zu
kommen tatsächlich eine Frage ist die
man sich noch mal gesondert überlegen
muss im Sinne von wollen wir uns das
wirklich antun Thüringen als No Go Land
so eine Stimmung auch die Wirtschaft
macht sich Sorgen unter den mehr als
3500 Unterstützern des Bündnisses viele
Industrieunternehmen wie jeen Optik im
Herbst hatte der Konzern schon eine
eigene Kampagne gestartet bleib offen
werden Mitarbeiter damit dann wollte ich
auch zeigen und dann Hoffnung geben also
für diese neue Generationen von
internationale Studenten da sie auch
schaffen Thüringen hat zwar viel schöne
Landschaft aber kaum großstätdte um
Fachkräfte zu holen und zu halten
müssten hier noch mehr die
Rahmenbedingungen stimmen wir sind ja
ein Unternehmen das aus jener aus
Thüringen kommt aber international tätig
ist mit 4in5000 Mitarbeitern davon 1700
hier in
aus mehr als 30 Nationen und das allein
glaube ich beschreibt schon wie wichtig
es für uns ist ein offenes
willkommensklima zu haben der Auftag der
Initiative trifft nun zeitlich genau mit
der Protestwelle auf den Straßen gegen
Rechtsextreme zusammen Demos auch in
Thüringen ein wirgefühl sie hoffen
dieses Momentum übers Wahljahr zu tragen
das ist ja ganz toll was uns alle
zutiefst berührt dass jetzt die Stille
Mitte die sehr breit auf
sich selbst wahrnimmt ihre
Selbstwirksamkeit auch wahrnimmt
infokampagnen Aktionstage Social Media
Konzerte das ist der Plan die Frage aber
ob er aufgeht in der politischen
Realität vielleicht schon nächsten
Sonntag im sakreis zur Stichwahl um den
Landratsposten im ersten Wahlgang hatte
der AFD Kandidat klar
vornelegen so jetzt weitere Nachrichten
von heute in der Übersicht mit dir
Gund in Deutschland haben antisemitische
Straftaten seit dem 7 Oktober deutlich
zugenommen der Terrorangriff der Hamas
habe auch auf deutschen Straßen eine
Welle von Judenhass ausgelöst erklärte
der
antisemitismusbeauftragte der
Bundesregierung klein das
Bundeskriminalamt habe
2249 antisemitische Straftaten in
dreieinhalb Monaten registriert fast so
viele wie im gesamten Vorjahr sorge
bereite die Bedrohung durch islamistisch
motivierten antisemitis
in Israel hat die Armee erneut Einwohner
der schwer umkämpften Stadt hananunis
zur Flucht aufgerufen ein
Militärsprecher kündigte mehrstündige
Kampfpausen an zur Versorgung der
Menschen zugleich sollen laut Hammers
mindestens 20 Zivilisten in Gaza getötet
worden sein als sie auf Hilfslieferungen
warteten das israelische Militär will
die Berichte
Prüfen der Vorschlag eines ringtausches
zu zur Unterstützung der Ukraine mit
Marschflugkörpern stößt bei Vertretern
von FDP GRÜNEN und CDU auf Skepsis
London soll Medienberichten zufolge
vorgeschlagen haben dass die Bundeswehr
Taurus Marschflugkörper an
Großbritannien oder Frankreich liefern
solle diese Länder könnten im Gegenzug
ähnliche Waffensysteme an die Ukraine
weitergeben die FDP Politikerin Stck
Zimmermann forderte erneut das
taurussystem sofort an die Ukraine
abzugeben es sei deutlich besser als die
Waffensysteme der
Verbündeten der ukrainische Präsident
selenski hat eine internationale
Untersuchung zum Absturz des russischen
militärfliegers bei belgurot gefordert
er äußerte sich nicht zu den Vorwürfen
aus Moskau die Ukraine habe die Maschine
abgeschossen nach russischen Angaben
wurden dabei 65 ukrainische
Kriegsgefangene getötet dafür gibt es
bislang keine Beweise zur Stunde berät
der UN Sicherheitsrat in einer von
Russland beantragten
Dringlichkeitssitzung
über den
Absturz der Zugverkehr in Deutschland
war auch am zweiten Streiktag weitgehend
lahm gelegt ungefähr 20% der
Verbindungen im Fernverkehr konnten laut
Bahn aufrechterhalten werden die
lockführergewerkschaft hatte zu
Kundgebungen in mehreren Städten
aufgerufen Forderungen wieder an den
Verhandlungstisch zurückzukehren lehnt
die GDL weiterhin ab zentral für Sie
kürzere Arbeitszeiten für
Schichtarbeiter Deutschland speist immer
mehr Wind und Solarstrom ins Netz ein
der Anteil erneuerbarer Energien
Entschuldigung der Anteil erneuerbareer
Energien wächst aber es gibt einen doch
ziemlich bedeutenden Haken nämlich dann
wenn der Wind nicht weht die Sonne nicht
scheint sprich die Stromgewinnung ist
klimafreundlich aber sie schwankt den
gleich sollen neue Gaskraftwerke
sicherstellen so sieht das die
kraftwerksstrategie der Bundesregierung
vor die aber alles andere als in
trockenen Tüchern ist heute gab es einen
neuen Anlauf zwischen Kanzleramt
Wirtschafts Finanzministerium und
Energiebranche es haakt am Geld und so
könnte plötzlich die Kohle wieder
wichtiger werden als eigentlich geplant
wie Peter Bömer
zeigt das Gaskraftwerk in Hamm zwei
Blöcke versorgen fast 2 Millionen
Haushalte mit Strom auf der Wiese
nebenan würde die trianelgruppe ein
Verband mit 53 Stadtwerken gern einen
dritten Block bauen im Rahmen der
Energiewende aber sie scheuen den
stsschuss weil die sogenannte
kraftwerkstrategie der Bundesregierung
bisher nicht
kommt also ich finde es schon
bedauerlich dass wir es nicht schaffen
konkrete Rahmenbedingung für diesen
benötigten
Zubau wasserstofffähiger Gaskraftwerke
zu schaffen wenn wir gleichzeitig aus
der Kohle aussteigen wollen es fehlen
allerdings die Rahmenbedingung um diese
Investition über die nächsten Jahre zu
refinanzieren Rahmenbedingungen für
einen veränderten Rahmen Deutschland
will koolitionsvertrag im Idealfall bis
2030 raus aus der Braunkohle dann sollen
80% des Stroms aus erneuerbaren Energien
kommen doch wenn der Wind nicht weht
oder die Sonne nicht scheint braucht man
Reserven dutzende Gaskraftwerke sollen
gebaut werden das Problem für die
Konzerne die Erneuerbaren wachsen immer
weiter die gasreserve braucht man dann
immer seltener und auch nur
stundenweise damit sich das Ganze am
Ende aber auch rechnet braucht die
Wirtschaft Finanzgarantien für die
Gaskraftwerke denn die können nur selten
Geld verdienen da muss entweder der
Strompreis in dieser Zeit sehr sehr hoch
werden und ob das auf Dauer akzeptiert
wird das ist zweifelhaft und das heißt
dann müssen wir müsste man
alternativunternehmen dafür bezahlen
dass sie diese Kraftwerke für den
Notfall oder für den Fall in dem nicht
genug erneuerbare zur Verfügung stellen
dann auch vorhalten die Zeit drängt 6
Jahre heißt es dauert es von der Planung
bis zur Fertigstellung es müsste also
schon jetzt Planungssicherheit herrschen
gibt's keine Gaskraftwerke muss der
Strom woanders herkommen wenn diese
Kraftwerke die wir dringend brauchen
nicht kommen dann gibt das zwei
Möglichkeiten entweder Gerät die
Versorgungssicherheit in Gefahr oder
weil wir Versorgungssicherheit immer
gewährleisten müssen das ist ja auch
unser Ziel dann müssen die
Kohlekraftwerke länger laufen und wie
sieht es überhaupt beim Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren aus beim 80% Ziel also das
Deutsche Institut für
Wirtschaftsforschung verfolgt den
Fortschritt in einem Monitoring bei der
Photovoltaik liegt Deutschland danach
derzeit über den Ausbauzielen bei der
Windkraft an Land aber hingt der Ausbau
weiterhin
hinterher bei der Windkraft an Land sind
wir im Moment deutlich zu langsam
unterwegs das Ziel sind 115 GW im Jahr
2030 mit dem aktuellen Tempo der letzten
12 Monate würden wir nur auf so gut 81
gab kommen hier brauchen wir also eine
eine Beschleunigung des Tempos um den
Faktor 3 wir müssen im Mittel dreimal so
schnell ausbauen bis 2030 sollten die
80% verfehlt werden müssten die
Kohlekraftwerke länger laufen aus dem
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium heißt es
man halte am Kohleausstieg idealerweise
bis 2030 fest und was die
kraftwerkstrategie angeht man arbeitet
dran in HAM und anderswo müssen Sie also
weiterwarten wir bleiben noch Moment
beim Geld mit dir gunduller die
Europäische Zentralbank hat die
Leitzinsen zum dritten Mal infolge
unverändert belassen das hatten die
Finanzmärkte so erwartet auch nach
entsprechenden Äußerungen von EZB
Präsidentin lagard kürzlich Frank
betmann an der Börse was erwarten die
Experten dort wird gefeiert wann könnte
denn eine Zinswende kommen na das heute
noch nicht eingeläutet wurde tut der
Feierlaune sie merken das keinen Abbruch
Neujahrsempfang der Industrie und
Handelskammer hier auf dem Parkett die
EZB aber um die Frage zu beantworten
spielt auf Zeit Zinswende frühestens im
Sommer die Währungshüter schauen derzeit
sehr genau darauf wie sich die Löhne
entwickeln droht da möglicherweise über
steigende Gehälter die Rückkehr der
Inflation durch die stark gestiegenen
Leitzinsen ist die teurerung bis dato in
der Eurozone merklich zurückgegangen von
über 10% noch im Oktober
2022 auf zuletzt nur noch
2,9% noch aber so die Lesart der
Währungshüter ist das inflationsgespenst
nicht nachhaltig verscheucht und so
lässt eine Leitzinssenkung noch auf sich
warten wir müssen noch kurz beim Thema
bleiben denn auf Tages und Festgeld gibt
es schon jetzt weniger Zinsen worauf
müssen sich Sparer einstellen ja richtig
auch Geschäftsbanken rechnen mit
niedrigeren Leitzinsen senken daher
nicht nur für Spareinlagen sondern auch
für Hypotheken die Zinsen Zinsen für
zweijähriges Festgeld sind
durchschnittlich auf
2,79% gefallen und wer Baugeld für 10
Jahre aufnimmt muss dafür inzwischen im
Mittel nur noch
3,45% bezahlen also auch ohne dazutun
der EZB sieht man bereits die Zinswende
fr betmann noch einen schönen Abend in
Frankfurt noch nie haben in Deutschland
so viele Menschen gelebt wie im
vergangenen Jahr laut vorläufiger
Schätzung des Statistischen Bundesamts
waren es zum Jahresende
84,7 Millionen das sind gut 300.000 mehr
als im Vorjahr und das obwohl die Zahl
der Todesfälle die der Geburten nach wie
vor deutlich übersteigt Grund für das
bevölkerungspl ist die
Zuwanderung der frühere
Verfassungsschutzpräsident Maren will
nach eigenen Angaben aus der CDU
austreten vor knapp einem Jahr hatte die
cdupitze ein Parteiausschlussverfahren
gegen ihn eingeleitet mit dem Vorwurf
der Radikalisierung und fehlender
Abgrenzung zur AFD Maßen hatte vor
kurzem die Gründung einer eigenen Partei
angekündigt aus der erzkonservativen
werteunion
heraus nach lagiatsvorwürfen gegen die
kovorsitzende der AFD Alice Weidel in
Bezug auf ihre Doktorarbeit hat die
zuständige Universität bei reut die
Prüfung der Vorwürfe eingestellt
vereinzelt sein zwar Zitierfehler zu
finden das reiche aber nicht aus um grob
fahrlässiges oder absichtliches
wissenschaftliches Fehlverhalten zu
belegen die japanische Raumfahrtbehörde
hat erste Bilder ihrer Punktlandung auf
dem Mond veröffentlicht als F Nation war
es Japan am Samstag gelungen mit einer
unbemannten Sonde auf dem Mond zu landen
und das nur etwa 55 m vom angepeilten
Zielort entfernt allerdings die Sonde
steht offenbar kopfüber soass die
Solarzellen derzeit keinen Strom
erzeugen
können wir hoffen auf einen Sahnetag
sagt der Bundestrainer Morgen wenn
Deutschlands Handballer bei der Heim em
um den Einzug ins Finale spielen und
gegen die haushohen Favoriten und
Weltmeister aus Dänemark muss es schon
mehr als ein kleines sahniges Häubchen
sein der Heimvorteil ist Ihnen sicher
diese Wand aus 10tausenden Fans wie
überhaupt die Europameisterschaft der
Handballer bereits jetzt ein echter
Magnet ist mit gigantischen
fernseheinschaltquoten die jeden Krimi
abhängen die Handball EM zeigt was die
fußballem erst noch schaffen muss ein
ganzes Land das auf einen Sahnetag hofft
Jochen
Esser man kennt sich in der Handballwelt
Deutschland gegen Dänemark geleitet von
zwei sehr erfahrenen Trainern
Deutschlands 64-jähriger Alfred
geslasson und Dänemarks Nikolai Jakobsen
5 ist einer die besten Trainer die je
gewesen sein und das wissen wir auch
morgen er hat eine riesenerfahrung auf
die Bank und wird auch ke FAK morgen
sein es Lob von Jakobsen dennoch sind
seine denen momentan das nonpl Ultra im
Handball nach dem Titel Hattrick bei den
letzten Weltmeisterschaften ist die
Struppe auf der Jagd nach em Gold
zuletzt vor 12 Jahren die haben zwei
überragende junge Spieler mit gizzel und
bitlig aber die haben da auch daneben
eine sehr viele sehr erfahrene gute
Spieler die sind eine
breite die beste Mannschaft der Welt
denke ich und und spielen natürlich auch
falen Handball Deutschland im wellenteil
bei der Heim em gestern die Niederlage
gegen Kroatien der Frust musste weg die
Auswahl bekämpft ihn mit einer
fleischorgie die Konzentration liegt auf
dem entscheidenden Spiel in Köln
getragen von der Kulisse wir können
morgen alles reinwerfen mit 20 000
Menschen im Rücken und wenn eine Halle
dafür geeignet ist kleine handballwunder
zu schreiben dann diese wir wissen dass
morgen wird schwer sein wir wissen auch
dass und da haben wir von Anfang ang
gesagt wenn wir gut spielt
dann wird es auch schwer für für die
anderen un zu schlagen und das ist
eigentlich auch unser Motto für morgen
die DHB Auswahl hofft nach dem WM-Titel
2007 im eigenen Land in Köln sowie den
goldtriumphen bei den
Europameisterschaften 2016 und 2004 auf
das nächste
Wintermärchen jo so ist es und
donnerstags an dieser Stelle empfehlen
wir Ihnen die Kollegin Maybritt ilner
traditionsgemäß und heute diese Frage
wütende Mitte vergisst die Ampel die
fleißigen und um 030 Uhr meldet sich
nasin göckte mir mit unserem heute
journal Update so wir zwei sind morgen
wieder für Sie da in der Halbzeitpause
des handballhalbfinales Deutschland
gegen Dänemark an einem Sahnetag bis
dann tschüss
tschüss
[Musik]
schön guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter der Regen der
kommenden Nacht ist hauptsächlich dieser
Warmfront hier geschuldet verlagert sich
allmählich nach Südosten aber dahinter
kommt die Kaltfront die bringt noch mehr
Regen morgen auch im Tagesverlauf dazu
legt der Wind ordentlich zu aber wenn
die Kaltfront durch ist dann lockert es
auf und es zeigt sich sogar die Sonne
wieder schauen wir in die kommende Nacht
und da ist der Regen schon da und der
hängt mit der Warmfront zusammen im
Nordwesten mit der Kaltfront hier regnet
es kräftiger und der Wind ist auch
stärker und das bei tiefsten
Temperaturen von 0° im Osten und 9° ganz
im Westen z.B hier am niederrehein
Morgen ist dann viel los beim Wetter der
die Kaltfront schwenkt einmal von
Nordwest Richtung Südost dabei gibt es
kräftige Schauer zwischendurch auch ein
bisschen Sonnenschein zum nach ag
lockert es aber dann auf und die Sonne
kommt dann häufiger hervor und der Wind
ist dann stark bis stürmisch während der
Kaltfront passassage das schauen wir uns
hier noch mal genauer an in der
norddeutschen Tiefebene 60 bis 90 km pro
Stunde Richtung Nordsee bei 11 km pro
Stunde das sind orkanartige böhnen ja
und die Temperaturen dazu höchste Werte
mit 7 bis 13° vor allem nach Südwesten
hin und Südosten ziemlich mild die
nächsten Tage ziemlich ruhiges Wetter
nach Nebel Sonnenschein Samstag 3 bis 9°
Montag dann 4 bis 13° und damit einen
schönen Abend